بايدي فلاحين بسطاء تملا سله غذاء جنوب
شرقي اسيا لكن نقص مياه الري دفع كثيرين
من فلاحين كمبوديا الى العزوف عن زراعه
الارز والبحث عن اعمال بديله
اما مايكير فقد استبشرت خيرا بفيضان نهر
الميكونج العام الماضي بعد سنوات من تراجع
منسوبه
ولا جاءت الى الحصاد باله حديثه
عندما تغمر مياه الفيضان حقل الارز تزيد
من خصوبه التربه وقد توقعت حصادا جيدا هذا
العام بعد فيضان النهر العام الماضي وهو
ما لم يحدث منذ سنوات يعد السمك الثروه
الرئيسيه الثانيه في كنبوديا وتقدر قيمتها
لدول حوض الميكونج بنحو 17 مليار دولار
سنويا
لكن سكان البيوت العائمه فيه مهددون
بفقدان ارزاقهم
فحصيله من صيد السمك لم تعد تفي بحاجات
اسرته البسيطه ويخشى ان ياتي يوم يلحق فيه
برفاقه الذين تخلوا عن مهنه الصيد كانهم
نعم
كنا اكثر من 100 صياد رحل معظمهم بسبب قله
الاسماك ولا اعرف مهنه غيرها منذ 30 سنه
تقريبا
ست دول تشترك في مياه نهر الميكونج هي
الصين وفيتنام والتايلاند ولاوس وكمبوديا
وميانمار وهو شريان حياه بالنسبه لها ورغم
الاتفاقيات المبرمه لاستغلال مياه النهر
فان نشطاء البيئه يحذرون من ازمه متوقعه
الاضرار التي تلحق بسكان حوض الميكونج
سببها التغير المناخي وبناء السدود لتوليد
الطاقه الكهرومائيه والمتضرر الاكبر هو
كمبوديا بانها دوله المصب
استخراج الرمال من قاع النهر لاستعمالها
في البناء نشاط يتزايد ويزداد معه الطلب
على رمال النهر من قبل دول الجوار مع
ارتفاع كل درجه في سلم النمو الاقتصادي
فهي ثروه طبيعيه لا غنى عنها لكمبوديا
لكنها تتسبب في انجراف التربه ما يهدد
سكان ضفاف نهر الميكونج مقص مياه نهر
الميكونج يعني للكمبوديين نقصا في ماده
الغذاء الرئيسيتين لديهم السمك والارز
يضاف الى اضرار يكون خبراء البيئه ان
سببها مشاريع ضخمه تقام على النهر
سامر علاوي الجزيره